as entertaining as they are some scary
movies have more than their share of
narrative issues
and if you pull that one plot thread the
whole story starts to unravel
from slasher classics to zombie
blockbusters these are the horror movies
with some of the biggest plot holes
john carpenter's halloween is a horror
classic that spawned an entire franchise
it's a perfect example of the slasher
genre that became so popular in the
1970s and 80s
even today people still wear michael
myers infamous mask on halloween
in the world of horror movies the mask
has become iconic
even if you've never seen the film
you've probably seen the mask
oddly enough a mistake involving the
mask creates a plot hole within the
original film
michael is seen wearing it several times
before someone actually breaks into a
hardware store and steals some masks
along with a couple other items on every
serial killer's shopping list
all they took was some halloween mask a
rope and a couple of knives
the mysterious thief is clearly supposed
to be michael
but the timeline is backward it might
make sense if there were actually two
killers running around wearing the same
mask
but that is definitely not the narrative
of halloween this could have been easily
remedied by including the incident in
the hardware store before michael was
ever shown wearing the mask but
for some reason the filmmakers didn't
think this was necessary
in the 1986 remake of the fly rogue
scientist
seth brundle believes he has invented a
way for humans to teleport between
locations
he hopes that his two telepods will make
this possible and he thinks that he's
getting very close to victory
however they're not perfect just yet he
tests them out with a baboon that
results in the animal being turned
inside out
somehow he's confident enough to try
teleporting himself
unfortunately his experiment goes
horribly wrong
a fly slips into the telepod during the
experiment
over the following days he realizes that
his dna has merged with the insect
and brundle is rapidly transforming into
a bizarre
new hybrid i'm becoming
brundle fly so if multiple organisms
enter the telepod together
they can merge into one but this
explanation doesn't actually hold up
under scrutiny
technically the telepod would be full of
invisible bacteria as well
so if the machine had the power to
combine the dna of multiple living
creatures
brundo should have become some sort of
human fly bacteria hybrid he would
transform into an even stranger creature
than he becomes in the film's final act
in any long-running franchise fans are
bound to spot a few contradictions and
continuity issues
and the friday the 13th films are no
exception with 12 movies a tv series and
a few novelizations and comic books
the iconic villain jason has been
terrorizing people for decades
in 2003 horror fans saw jason face off
against freddy krueger
from the nightmare on elm street
franchise in the film freddy vs jason
as the two battle it out freddy uses
jason's biggest weakness against him
water supposedly jason is terrified of
water because of what happened to him at
crystal lake as a child so you are
afraid of something after all but this
left long time fans confused in the
original friday the 13th movie
audiences see jason in the lake he's no
stranger to the water
and in later films jason finds himself
in heavy rain and lakes more than once
it just doesn't seem likely that jason
suddenly developed an intense fear of
water
when he came face to face with freddy
there's one particular scene in the lost
world jurassic park that still causes
debate
decades after the movie's release
towards the end of the film
the ss venture crashes into a dock while
transporting a captured t-rex
it's quickly revealed that all the crew
members have been killed it's implied
that the t-rex on the ship was
responsible for the carnage
however the t-rex is still contained in
the cargo hold
and the ship hasn't sustained any major
damage not even the control room
where the crew was killed there's really
no satisfactory explanation for it
within the film
however there is one popular theory
some fans believe that velociraptors
were able to board the ship and kill the
crew
also a raptor is small enough to
realistically fit into the control room
so this explanation makes more sense
than a giant t-rex squeezing in
but in the final cut of the film nothing
was added to fill that gap in the
narrative
and viewers were left wondering how a
murderous t-rex managed to let itself
out of a cage
slay a ship full of people and then
cleverly lock itself
back in life uh
finds a way in signs aliens invade earth
but as it turns out they have a specific
weakness that makes them relatively easy
to defeat
after his home is infiltrated graham
hess tries to protect his family from
the invaders with little success
it looks like the end is near until his
brother meryl hits an alien with a
baseball bat and knocks it against a
glass of water
surprisingly the liquid burns its skin
and they realize
that water is fatal to the aliens here's
the problem
if these aliens were really allergic to
water they would have perished shortly
after entering earth's atmosphere
because as anyone with a basic
understanding of science knows
water vapor is present in the air we
can't help but wonder if all of their
ships landed in areas without any
rainfall
or high humidity plus shouldn't an
advanced civilization capable of space
travel have realized that earth mostly
consists of something that is deadly to
them
the twist at the end can be shocking
when you're caught up in the excitement
of the story
but only if you don't think about it too
hard it's also odd that this revelation
was actually discussed
earlier in the film i heard a theory
that uh they don't like places near
water
you'd think that everyone would be
prepared to take on the aliens with
buckets of water and squirt guns but of
course
that would have been a very different
movie
[Music]
in zombieland the protagonists have all
been dodging the undead for a few months
by the time we meet up with them
columbus tallahassee wichita and little
rock know that they need to keep their
wits about them at all times
that makes their decision to let loose
at an abandoned amusement park come
across as
pretty out of character for all of them
wichita and little rock have heard that
there aren't any zombies in the area
but it seems unlikely that they would
all be on board for this plan
especially since the park doesn't
measure up to tallahassee standards
that place totally blows eventually
wichita and little rock get the lights
and the rides up and running which
begs another question how is power still
being supplied to the park in this
post-apocalyptic society
naturally zombies begin flocking to the
noise and lights of the park
and the group has to escape it all makes
for a dramatic scene
but it's not like the foursome never
makes mistakes when it comes to
protecting themselves
however this just feels like they were
looking for trouble
when they should have known better a
quiet place
is centered around a unique concept the
world has been invaded by some sort of
alien species that hunts
solely with their sense of hearing the
abbott family
lee evelyn and their children reagan
beau and marcus
has been surviving by communicating in
sign language and restructuring their
entire lifestyle so they barely make a
sound
when beau takes a battery-powered toy
from a convenience store and alerts a
creature to his presence
he is killed instantly which is likely
what prompts lee and evelyn to try for
another baby
despite the high risk by the end of the
film the family has experienced
even more loss but considering how
sensitive the aliens are to every little
sound
it's remarkable that any of them have
survived we're supposed to believe that
the family has managed to build a
soundproof room for their newborn baby
coated their farm with sand to mask
their footsteps silently harvesting
crops for food
and somehow masked every random sneeze
without getting the attention of the
ravenous creatures
it's a genuinely suspenseful and moving
film but when you really think about it
the central premise is pretty thin when
the writer started working on the script
for paranormal activity
they never anticipated that one
throwaway line would actually create a
massive plot hole within the franchise
in the first paranormal activity film
mika
and katie worry about the mysterious
events going on in their house
so they hire a psychic to come over and
give them advice on the situation
he warns the couple to avoid negative
energy in the house
then mika attempts to make a joke you
shouldn't let your mother come over
anymore
paranormal activity 3 came out a few
years later and suddenly that quip about
katie's mother no longer
made any sense a major plot point in
paranormal activity 3
is the death of katie's mother when she
was just a little girl
so it seems that the filmmakers just
decided to look the other way on this
one
or another plausible explanation could
be that mika is a huge jerk
jordan peele proved himself to be a
masterful filmmaker with his directorial
debut
get out but upon closer inspection
there's a nagging plot hole in his
follow-up film
us when adelaide wanders into a house of
mirrors as a little girl
she's pulled underground by her tether a
doppelganger who is likely the result of
a government experiment gone wrong
the tether takes her place in the
outside world adelaide however
suffers in a labyrinth full of other
tethers who are forced to mimic the
lives of their counterparts above ground
the real adelaide eventually decides to
lead a rebellion
she organizes the tethers and plans for
them to go above ground
kill off their doubles and start a
revolution when they rise above
the tethers are all wearing red
jumpsuits and carrying gold scissors
it definitely makes for some striking
visuals but how did they get the
materials or
funds to create the uniforms it's a
massive operation
and the film never gives viewers a
logical explanation about it
don't feed them after midnight don't
expose them to sunlight
and do not under any circumstances get
them wet
those are the rules for taking care of
the mysterious creatures called
the mogwai and gremlins the mogwai can
be deceptively cute
but their aggression can also prove
deadly gremlins is certainly endearing
and entertaining and it's one of the
rare crossovers between the horror and
holiday film genres but the wintry
setting actually presents a plot hole
if the mogwai gets wet it will multiply
and you'll have a serious problem on
your hands
however there's snow on the ground
during the film and the mogwai are shown
running around in it many times
as pretty much everyone on the planet
knows including screenwriters
snow is just frozen water crystals by
the film's own logic
they should have multiplied like crazy
almost every time they stepped outside
the town would have been overtaken in
minutes but this wasn't how it played
out
luckily for the people of kingston falls
the mogwai only multiplied when they
touched
liquid water i am a legend follows
virologist robert neville
as he struggles to survive in the ruins
of manhattan after a devastating virus
sweeps across the nation the disease has
killed most of the world's population
and turned a small percentage of people
into violent zombies
when the film begins neville only has
his german shepherd sam for
companionship
he spends his days trying to discover a
cure for the virus and attempting to
contact any remaining survivors
through a radio broadcast one day the
unthinkable finally happens
neville meets two other survivors anna
and ethan have driven to new york from
maryland after hearing neville's
broadcast
there's only one small problem with that
explanation
it simply isn't possible at least not in
the theatrical version of the movie
after the virus started spreading
manhattan was completely quarantined
and all the bridges leading to the
island were destroyed as a result
there is no way that anna could have
just driven to manhattan to find neville
while it's cleared up in the film's
alternate version that not every
bridge was destroyed the theatrical cut
still leaves us with questions
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite horror movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one